A small Texas town divided at odds over
what Elon Musk and SpaceX
X have done to their peaceful livelihoods
as they sit in the shadow of behemoths.
SpaceX facilities
On the flip side,
it's also brought an economic boom.
Ed Lavandera is OUTFRONT
Looks like the surface of the moon.
Yeah, it looks otherworldly.
Take a walk through the sand dunes
surrounding the SpaceX
launch pad tower in south Texas.
And the remnants of April's
launch
of the most powerful rocket
ever built are still everywhere.
These pieces right here
were part of the launch pad. Yeah. Wow.
And this is only a quarter of a mile.
Maybe debris
that size went three quarters of a mile.
At least after the launch just in LA,
Claire documented the aftermath.
He's a biologist
with the Coastal Bend Bays
and Estuaries Program,
a group
that's tracking the environmental impact
of space
launches on the Boca Chica Peninsula.
The area is now often
referred to as Elon Musk's Starbase.
It is in the middle of a wildlife
refuge and state park lands.
And, you know,
this this
area isn't really meant to be disturbed.
That's kind of the point of protecting
these areas,
is to protect them
for the wildlife
and for public enjoyment as well.
In April, thousands of people descended
on South Texas
to witness the thunderous
launch of the SpaceX
Starship Rocket and heavy booster
The rocket's three engines
disintegrated much of the concrete
launch pad.
And then a few minutes later,
the rocket blew up
before reaching SpaceX,
literally like a meteor.
Debris from the launch left craters
in the sand flats.
Smaller pieces peppered the landscape
like a shotgun blast at close range.
Tangled rebar was thrown nearly
a mile away.
Vegetation near the site was scorched.
The area is a critical nesting ground
for threatened and endangered wildlife.
What is your concern
about what this place
is going to look like?
Yeah, well,
that's the that's the question is
where does it stop, really?
Another explosion another explosion.
Another explosion eventually.
Like this
is not a wildlife refuge anymore.
It's not a place for the public
to go and see natural beauty.
It's for space testing and space travel.
And that's it.
The April launch has resurfaced,
the tension
between Elon Musk's SpaceX
and its critics here in South Texas.
This graffiti appeared just a week later.
Several environmental groups are suing
the Federal Aviation Administration
to take stricter oversight
of the private space company's
launch plans.
SpaceX did not respond
to CNN's requests for comment.
It's not clear
when SpaceX will launch again.
Elon Musk says he'd like to try
by the end of July or early August.
But the Federal Aviation
Administration tells CNN
that it will not speculate on a timeline
to approve future flights.
The FAA says that SpaceX has yet
to complete
its final mishap investigation
and that the company still needs
to identify
and implement
corrective actions
to ensure public safety.
A lot of it is space themed.
Barton Bickerton opened Hopper
House Bar and Grill almost two years ago.
It's become a popular spot
for space sex employees,
locals and space tourists.
Business has been booming.
We had a lot of regulars
that were coming in every day
and really supportive of it,
and now we're kind of you know,
again, they were just kind of shocked
by it.
So, like, more nervous about what
the impact and all that might be.
There's no turning back from this now,
right?
There's no way
that they're not
going to keep launching from here.
These guys will figure it out.
You know,
they'll figure out what they need to do.
The space boom has also triggered
a real estate boom.
This is old Brownsville
but this is old Brownsville.
You grew up a few blocks.
I grew up
two blocks down that way on Levy.
So, yeah, I it's home.
Josette Hinojosa
isn't sure how much longer
she can afford to live here.
She says her rent jumped from $650
a month to a thousand in just two years.
Hinojosa says
many families are selling their homes
because they can't afford
the taxes anymore.
That is my fear for my neighbors.
That they will be shut out.
They will be pushed
out of the neighborhood
and the place that we know is home.
Brownsville is in
one of the poorest counties in the state.
But the median home
price has more than doubled
since space broke ground here in 2014,
far outpacing
the statewide price increase
It's like this
polarizing issue within our city
because you have people who work for them
and then you've got
people like me
who are like,
you guys are
looking at the bigger picture
Space
X has the full throttle support
of local political leaders
who see space as a major economic driver
that will fundamentally change
the future of the Rio Grande Valley.
The company is expanding its footprint
on the South Texas
coast,
and Elon Musk has committed millions
to the community.
We're inventing the wheel
with the largest
potential spaceship that's ever been
launched or developed.
Cameron County Judge Eddie Trevino says.
It's like the early days of Nasser
when the space agency
developed Cape Canaveral, Florida.
I guarantee you
any other community
in this country
would love to have Space X
launching in their backyard
because of what it would mean
from an economic development standpoint,
from an educational standpoint,
from a tourism standpoint.
Ed Lavandera, CNN, Brownsville, Texas.